rvu said in the past and prior
interviews that one of the number one
reasons people quit the entertainment
industry is because they don't have the
contacts or connections yeah so why and
and how can we turn it around well you
know when I first started as an actor in
New York there was no social media I
mean like you know was Friendster and
maybe the early days of Facebook and
things of that nature but nobody was
looking at it as you know something that
a tool that we could use to meet people
that would further our careers and a lot
of my friends that were in New York who
were actors really really talented
people ended up leaving for all the
reasons that you would imagine you know
they had tried it out for five years and
you know they now they wanted to have a
family or they you know they needed to
bring in an income and they just had to
you know and it was sad to see and that
always stayed with me because you know
again when you were creative and you see
creative people leave that you know
leave the biz or leave you know give up
the ghost so to speak it bothers you
because you're like man there's so much
talent right that always stayed with me
so when the embryonic idea of stage 32
kind of came into play while I was
working on an independent film and I saw
the cast and crew come together as a
family and then go their separate ways
oh it's like summer camp we're gonna
stay together we're all gonna hang out
and everything and of course that
doesn't happen because everybody's got
to go do the next gig and you know and
then when you do hear from him again
it's like do you know any do you know
any place where I can get some work do
you know anything that's going on is can
you hire me for anything that made me
think back to my active friends back in
New York and it made me realize I looked
at myself because now at this point
social media had exploded and these you
know broad-based social media platforms
have exploded like Facebook but I wasn't
on it because I didn't see the need for
it as far as my career was concerned so
that's what brought me to niche social
media and the idea of starting this site
and I feel like that is what is turning
it around I do feel like again the idea
that you know I am in this town and I am
looking for work you know in this
discipline and here's where I could go
to go try to find network or to make
connections that could lead me to a
job is the thing that's turning it
around you know one of the features we
have on the site is the stage 32 meetup
section and something we're enormous ly
proud of we've revamped the entire thing
and the whole idea is that yes
networking online is great it's great
for everybody but like I said earlier
there's nothing that replaces that
face-to-face interaction so what we
allow our members to do is to any member
can do this can set up a stage 32 meetup
in their town and take that networking
offline so you get these great big
groups that come together at a local bar
or maybe somebody's house or whatever to
do their networking there and it's
amazing the stories we hear the jobs
that come out of it you know that the
films that get launched the funding that
comes out of it you know because this
person knows that person and so on and
it's just something that wasn't
available to us ten years ago
you